give back every bit of money that you
got from I'm a celebrity to start with
um his book should be taken off the
shelves
um as in an apology apology is just not
going to cut it anymore and that's the
thing it's just unbelievable it really
really is and an apology is not really
just not good enough and yes he's got
he's you know his blood on his hands
it's just actually there's no words to
describe how I feel at the moment
um because you know we should have known
as well what was happening what was
going on but the vulnerability of people
everybody that was in Care Homes was
just a disgrace
he says mom
you know my mum worked until she was 72
years old yeah she had a great life and
it was only because of mild dementia
that she went into a care home because
as you know her children we were all
working
um if I could have and at that time if I
could have bought her home I actually
would have but it wasn't possible
because I still carried on working
throughout the whole of covid as I was
working in a school where I went in
every single day